my internet sucks oh God I need to have
somebody young look at what I pay a
month on uh whatever that Dish Network
it is and what I pay for cable and I
know that they I probably pay 300 a
month
I know there's a better way to do this I
know there's apps and and and and and
things you know I put it on my computer
and then I beam it to the T I know
there's a better way to do this I have
to be on some board at DirecTV where
they're just saying like I have to be
like a five-star client Under The
Heading he still hasn't figured it out
he doesn't understand there's a cheaper
way to get the exact same package and we
will never tell him as far as like
paying for cable a month or whatever the
I'm paying for satellite feed I
have to be in the top five in Los
Angeles I would say